talk will be Bymark fun an approximate
degree in quantum parlor events hey
thanks Rocco so today I'll be continuing
on the theme started by Sasha and it's
very nice talk about approximate degree
but this time I'll be speaking about
approximate degree lower balance and how
they can be used to prove lower balance
against functions of interest in quantum
computing now I guess I'm the last talk
before lunch so I should make a joke
about this but too hungry so let's just
get this over with
alright so again this is going to be a
talk about boolean functions which map
n-bit strings 0 1 into 0 1 and just as
with sauces talk I'll be speaking about
approximate degree so the approximate
degree of such a boolean function f is
the least degree of a real polynomial P
that approximates F point wise so you
know in general you can parameterize
this definition by a parameter epsilon
and require that P be close to F point
wise to with an error epsilon and when I
say approximate degree without
qualification I'm going to refer to the
one third approximate degree which is
going to be denoted by a dag of F in
this talk okay and this is an example
it's known that the one third
approximate degree of the or function on
n bits is asymptotically Rutan ok so
again as Sascha discussed approximate
degree both upper and lower bounds have
a number of applications throughout
theoretical computer science so again
upper bounds generally underlie lots of
algorithmic results and learning theory
in other areas as well as formula lower
bounds the focus of this talk again is
going to be on lower bounds for
approximate degree which have a lustrous
history in concrete
computational complexity ok the specific
application I want to focus on for
quantum query complexity so again it's
known that you know due to this
observation of bills Behrman Cleve
mosque under Wolff that any quantum
query algorithm making
t queries to its input has an acceptance
probability which can be written as a
degree 2t polynomial as input so in
particular a very powerful method of
proving lower bounds for quantum query
complexity is to say that any polynomial
that approximates the boolean function
of interests has to have high
approximate degree and hence have high
quantum query complexity all right
and again approximate degree underlies a
number of other applications and
communication complexity circuit
complexity relativized complexity and
has recently been used to build secret
sharing scheme with reconstruction
procedures in AC 0 okay so what I want
to do in this talk is take you on a
magical mystery tour of some approximate
degree lower bound so magical because I
think some of these ideas are really
quite beautiful mystery because I don't
have time to tell you about all of the
technical details so I want to start by
telling you about a powerful anyway on
one of the first techniques available
for proving approximate degree lower
bounds no scimitar ization and how it
can be used to understand the
approximate degree of one of the
simplest functions the and function then
I'll tell you about more complicated
technique moving beyond symmetrization
using the method of dual polynomials and
how it can be used to understand one of
the simplest non symmetric functions and
then finally I'll tell you about some
relatively recent work moving even
further beyond these techniques using
dual polynomials to get new results for
the approximate degree of AC zero and
specific functions of interest in
quantum computing alright so on till the
first parts the theorem I want to tell
you about is this result from this
seminal work of Nissan and Sega T
introducing the notion of approximate
degree we showed that the approximate
degree of the and function on n bits is
asymptotically rudin so again as Sascha
I mentioned the upper bound for this
follows from
chebyshev polynomials so a chebyshev
polynomial is some polynomial of degree
D that looks like this thing on the left
and after taking some affine
transformation of this polynomial you
get some univariate polynomial that
looks like this so it's going to hang
out around 0 up until
right before you hit one and then it's
going to shoot up okay so what's so
great about this well we can cook up
this affine transformation so that this
polynomial evaluates to 1 at 1 and again
hangs out between 0 and 1/3 up to about
1 minus 1 over and enhanced by just
applying this univariate polynomial to
the fractional Hamming weight of an
input and choosing the degree of the
polynomial to be square root of the
number of inputs n we get an
approximation to the N function so you
need it to shoot up from 1 minus 1 over
N to 1 so the degree depends on this gap
from 1 minus 1 over N to 1 over N and
it's going to be the square root of 1
over that cap all right
so nice on integrity also proved the
matching lower bound using this
technique called symmetrization which
goes back at least to the work of Minsky
and Papert on perceptrons and what they
showed is that basically this is the
only thing you can do so if you have any
polynomial P multivariate polynomial
that approximates the n function to it
and one-third on every input then you
can symmetrize it with respect to the
Hamming weight of the input and get a
univariate polynomial Q with the
property that's you know it hangs out
around 0 up to 1 minus 1 over again and
then shoots up to 1 and moreover this
univariate polynomial Q has degree which
is no more than that of the original
polynomial okay so the salient feature
about this univariate polynomial is that
it has a high derivative somewhere near
1 so it's you know shoots up with a
derivative at least about n so one can
use classic techniques from
approximation theory in particular there
I'm called Markov's inequality which
says that the degree of any univariate
part the derivative of any univariate
polynomial is going to be at most the
square of the degree as long as it stays
founded on this interval 0 1
okay so because this univariate
polynomial has to have a derivative of
at least n that means the degree of Q
and hence the degree of the original
polynomial P has to be at least through
dad all right
okay so symmetries ation turns out to be
quite a powerful technique and indeed
this paradigm of combining symmetries
ation plus classical techniques and
approximation Theory yields tight lower
bounds for symmetric boolean functions
and a more complicated way of using this
technique gives a tight lower bound for
the element distinctness function that
Sasha discussed the symmetries ation
doesn't tell the whole story in
particular there are certain non
symmetric functions for which
symmetrization alone doesn't seem
powerful enough so one such function is
this two level and/or tree where I take
the and function on say our inputs and
block compose it with the or function on
n inputs so by block composition I mean
I'm going to feed each of these are
copies of the or function a set of
disjoint inputs
okay now theorem I want to tell you
about is that the approximate degree of
this thing is the product of the
approximate degrees of the Constituent
functions so root R times root n okay so
the upper bound for this showing that
the approximate degree is at most root r
times root n was initially proved by
hoyer muska and de Wolfe who exhibited a
quantum query algorithm for this problem
but the more general proof of this
result and indeed for like block
compositions of boolean functions their
approximate degree was proved using this
notion of robust approximations so the
theorem says that's the approximate
degree of any block composition of two
functions F and G is that most up to a
contractor the product of the
approximate degrees of the Constituent
functions
now in terms of lower bounds again said
that the symmetries ation alone seems
not to be powerful enough to attack this
problem as evidenced by a line of work
proving suboptimal balance on this time
but I'm just function through
symmetrization alone so I'll tell you
now about a relatively recent technique
using the method of dual polynomials
which gets around this barrier
systemization
okay
so what is this method so the method is
based on linear programming duality so
what one does is one writes down this
question you know what is the best error
epsilon to which I can approximate the
boolean function f using some low degree
degree D polynomial okay and I'm going
to encode this question using a linear
program and it's going to be linear in
the air parameter epsilon as well as the
coefficients of the alleged
approximating polynomial P great now I'm
going to sit down and take the dual of
this which is going to be this thing
over here
doesn't really matter what this is I'll
give some interpretation of what it says
on the next slide but the point is that
you know any the the primal problem is
going to be infeasible if and only if I
can exhibit a good dual feasible
solution okay so just like weak duality
will allow me to show a lower bound on
the primal objective by just exhibiting
a good dual object and moreover this is
like a complete method for proving lower
bounds by strong duality because any
such lower bound will be witnessed by a
good dual polynomial all right so again
this is the theorem the approximate
degree of a function f is at least is
greater than D if and only if there's a
dual polynomial satisfying the
requirements of the dual program and
what are these requirements the first
requirement is just a normalization
condition on the dual polynomial so the
sum of the absolute values of the
polynomial over the boolean hypercube
has to be 1 the second condition is that
this dual polynomial sy has pure high
degree D meaning it's uncorrelated with
all low degree polynomials ok and then
the third condition is that the dual
polynomial C is well correlated so
correlated to at least epsilon with the
target function f ok so just some
intuition about what this thing is
saying so this condition here says that
psy is inherently you know a high degree
polynomial okay it's no component of psy
is
should buy low degree polynomials and
this last condition here says that psy
picks up a lot of you know it explains a
lot of the target function ass so
putting these together says that's a you
know a lot of this function f that we're
trying to approximate is inherently high
degree all right
okay so this method of dual polynomials
suggests a very natural approach to
proving lower bound for block compose
functions particularly ant or tree so
what you do is you know you use my
strong duality the fact that the
approximate degree of the ant function
is at least root R and the fact that the
approximate degree of the or function is
at least root n are both witnessed by
some dual polynomials and all you have
to do is you have to put these together
somehow so you're going to combine these
dual polynomial Sian and say or to
produce a new dual polynomial site
and/or for the ant or tree okay
and the specific technique that can be
used to construct such a polynomial goes
back to concurrent works of she Zhu Li
ensure stuff and this is it written out
ins full glory it's not terribly
important what this says but there's a
very nice interpretation of what this is
doing in terms of the language of secret
sharing and distributions which goes to
the goes back to the work of Emanuele
Andrey Bogdanov Kavali shy and Chris
Williamson so basically if you think of
a dual polynomials like a signed
distribution what this thing is is it's
going to give you a method for sampling
from the signed distribution for this
combined function and or what just says
you know sample from this outer dual
distribution sigh and and then you know
whatever you got from that you sample
inputs to each of the bottom level gates
just like independently from the product
distribution on those things
any questions
alright so in the last part of the talk
I want to tell you about some more
recent results again building on the the
prior two parts this talk to prove new
lower bounds for AC zero functions and
new lower bounds for functions of
interest in quantum computing so one of
the main motivating questions for this
last part of the talk is very basic
question so is there an AC zero function
with essentially maximal approximate
degree order n so you know every boolean
function has a exact representation as a
multi linear polynomial degree n but you
know we're far from understanding
whether you know if one relax us to
approximate degree you can get AC zero
functions with approximate degree that's
nearly maximal it was known on this
topic so again this work of Nissan and
Sega T showed that the approximate
degree of the or function and depth one
is read n and Aaronson and she showed
that there's a depth to circuit element
distinctness function with approximate
degree in the two-thirds but prior to
our work this was the best known for any
depth so in this work we showed that the
surjectivity function which played an
essential role in Sasha's talk has
approximate degree at least end of the
3/4 which matches the upper bound proved
by Sasha and moreover by recursively
applying the techniques used to prove
this lower bound we can get a bound of
the form n to the 1 minus Delta for any
positive constant Delta by going to
arbitrarily higher debts okay so this
result has a couple of applications and
computational learning theory if you
want to agnostically learn some class of
AC 0 functions and depth D doing so via
this polynomial regression framework
requires an exponential end of the 1
minus Delta number of features this also
gives a new and nearly optimal lower
bounds for the
awesome and randomized multi-party
communication of AC zero functions and
again building on this framework
introduced by Bogdanov at all we get
improved secret sharing scheme with
reconstruction in AC zero okay
so this result and the techniques used
to prove it have some other consequences
so again sort of the the core of all of
our results was this new lower bound of
end of the 3/4 for this specific
surjectivity function again by
recursively applying the techniques used
to prove this lower bound we get an end
to the 1 minus Delta a lower bound for
the depth log 1 over Delta H to 0
function but the proof strategy that we
employ to prove this lower bound turns
out to be somewhat more broadly useful
in particular a common proof strategy
gives us new lower bounds for host of
other problems of interest in quantum
computing including the K distinct miss
function that Sasha mentioned and as
well as some additional property testing
problems lower bounds against which were
not known using other techniques
available for proving lower bounds in
quantum computing ok any questions
all right so let me start by giving you
sort of the the high-level idea for how
we prove these new lower bounds that
move beyond black composition so the
first is to prove a hardness
amplification theorem for certain types
of non black composed functions which
keep them in AC zero okay and the second
step is going to be to express you know
surjectivity
k distinct Nisour whatever function were
interested in proving a lower bound
against in terms of simpler functions
using this hardness amplification
construction okay so let me give you a
bit of context about this question of
hardness amplification with an AC zero
so here's a sample of some theorems that
have been proved in recent years not
going to be fun for any of us to go
through this so let me just tell you the
template that all of these theorems
follow so what these theorems say so if
I have some function little F which is
hard to approximate by low degree
polynomial in a sense of having high
approximate degree then there's going to
be some gadget G for which I can block
compose G with F to obtain a function
big f which is going to be even harder
to approximate by low degree polynomials
in the sense of requiring either higher
degree or higher error okay
unfortunately any theorem that follows
this template is going to run into a
barrier proving lower balance which I
call the block composition barrier so
remember this upper bound that I told
you about is going to be an obstacle
here so this notion of robust polynomial
approximation shows that the approximate
degree of such a thing is always going
to be at most the product of the
Constituent approximate degrees and
hence if I'm going to try to prove a
lower bound against an AC zero function
in this way by just you know block
composing anzan doors I'm never going to
get the lower bound better than root n
where n is the total number of inputs of
the function okay so if we're shooting
for something better than root and we're
going to need to do something else okay
so what we do in this work is we prove a
new hardness amplification theorem for
degree that gets around this block
composition barrier okay so what do we
do we start with some function little F
that has
proximate degree at least e and let's
say f is computed by an AC zero function
with depth K on n inputs then what we're
gonna do is we're going to transform
this function little F into a function
big f on slightly more input so just
order n inputs and slightly higher depth
k plus 2 and also polynomial size such
that the approximate degree of this
function big f is at least the square
root of D multiplied by square root of n
ok so it's the geometric mean of the
approximate degree of the original
function and the number of input
variables n so in particular if I
started with a little F being something
like the and function which has
approximate degree root n then what I
get out of this is going to be a
function on roughly n variables that has
approximate degree end of the 3/4 yes
exactly if you were to do straight block
composition then you would get something
like this but the number of variables
would now be like N squared so again
recursively applying this hardness
amplification garum gives us our lower
bound for AC zero and then refining and
generalizing some of these techniques
lets us understand other specific
functions of interest ok so it's one
more time to draw the contrast between
this and prior work
so prior hardness amplification theorems
we're different in that they did
amplification sort of from the top you
what you do is you take some hard
function f you feed many disjoint copies
of this into some gadget G and you get
some hard function this way whereas what
we do is we do we take the opposite
perspective we do hardness amplification
from the bottom so you take your hard
function f and feed in many copies of
some gadget G essentially relying on
overlapping sets of inputs so we in
order to get anything to work we
definitely need to consider non black
compost functions ok so i've stated the
hardness amplification theorem sort of
in generic language and the rest of the
talk what i want to do is hone in on one
specific function so one specific
application of the hardest amplification
theorem
which is to understanding this
surjectivity function in particular the
search activity function is going to be
exactly what we get by applying our
hardness amplification theorem where the
starting function is the ant function
all right okay so surjectivity again
played a central role in Sasha's talk so
lets me remind you what it is so the
search activity function is going to be
parametrized by two numbers and an R and
the input to this thing is going to be a
list of n numbers each coming from this
range of size R and it's going to
evaluate to 1 or true if and only if
every item in this range 1 there are
appears somewhere in the input list okay
now just taking the natural encoding of
each of these range elements went
through R and binary reveals that this
is a boolean function on something like
n times log R bits and moreover this
function has really been of interest in
the study of approximate degree in
quantum query complexity for the reason
that's it has essentially maximal
quantum query complexity shown by B memo
Lucci
but the approximate degree is polynomial
smaller so it's Sasha said in his talk
it's at most R to the 3/4 ok so I want
to suggest why we should be able to
think of this surjectivity function as a
hardness amplified version of and ok so
to do so I'm going to define a sequence
of auxiliary variables each depending on
this input list s and the auxiliary
variable which is parametrized by some
range item R and some index into the
input list I is going to just indicate
whether the input list item si is equal
to the range item are all right so I can
express the surjectivity function as the
and
overall range items when there are of
the or overall input list elements of
this gadget testing whether that range
item is equal to that input list item ok
okay so I want to make a simple
observation so of course if we could
approximate this function and block
composed with or then we would get out
of sort of automatically a good
approximation to the search activity
function because each of these gadgets
you know only depends on log R bits so
we would get a function you know of a
proximate degree sorry we would get an
approximating polynomial of degree which
is the degree of what we needed to
approximate this and or tree multiplied
by a log R which for the purposes of
this talk I'll just ignore but something
even more is true so this function has
some additional structure so because
each of these gadgets yri is coming from
you know this equality test of something
in the input list I have the promise
that the Hamming weight of this thing is
going to be exactly end because at most
n of these gadgets are going to be
turned on by any input list s1 through
SN okay so in order to get a good
approximation to the surjectivity
function it suffice us to approximate
this and or tree only on inputs of
Hamming weight n
all right so the theorem I want to tell
you is that for some choice of
parameters where the size of the input
list and is roughly the order of
magnitude of the range size are the
approximate degree of the surjectivity
function is art at 3/4 okay which is
essentially the number of input
variables to the 3/4 okay and the way we
prove this lower bound proceeds in two
steps the first okay well so again this
whole like last part of the talk has
been about moving beyond black compose
functions but we're pretty bad at
understanding non-block compose
functions so the first thing we're gonna
do is reduce to a block compose function
and the way we're going to do so uses
the symmetry zation technique again
going back to Minsk and Peppard but more
specifically going back to work of them
- so roughly speaking what this stage
one does it shows that this strategy I
outlined on the previous slide of
approximating the block composition and
composed with or on inputs of Hamming
weight n is the only thing you can do
okay so even though surjectivity has
this additional structure that's you
know these gadgets come from some input
list really the only structure that's
going to help you algorithmically is the
fact that this thing has Hamming weight
and
all right and of course stage two is now
going to be to understand this block
compose function under a Hamming weight
promise so what we're going to do is
we're going to show that the approximate
degree of an block composed with or
restricted to inputs of Hamming weight
at most n is going to be R to the
three-fourths and this is going to use
part two of the talk which was the
method of dual polynomials alright and
specifically what we're going to do is
we're going to define this dual
polynomial that we had already
constructed for the block composition of
bandwidth or okay so in somewhat more
detail again what we want to show is
that the approximate degree of this
block compose function under a Hamming
weight promise is high well the way to
think about this in the dual world
because we're going to be operating
there is that there's a dual polynomial
witnessing the fact that an block
composed with or is high and moreover
this dual polynomial is supported only
on inputs of low Hamming weight okay so
a natural question you can ask is does
the dual polynomial that we are ready
constructed for the and or tree satisfy
this property well the answer has to be
no and you know in fact there's an upper
bound which shows that it can't be the
case so let's see what happens well okay
so this is the dual polynomial were
constructed for and or and what I want
to draw your attention to is this thing
over here so the product of the inner
dual polynomial over all of the blocks
okay so the problem is that the inner
dual polynomial sigh or in order to have
good pure high degree has to be nonzero
for inputs up to a maximal Hamming
weight n so in particular this combined
dual polynomial for the Andorra tree has
to be nonzero for up to maximal Hamming
weight R times n which is much bigger
than the end that we're shooting for so
well this dual polynomial has almost all
of the properties that we like has
appropriate l1 norm appropriate pure
high degree actually pure high degree
that's too good to be true
and a good correlation it's very far
from being supported on low Hamming
weight inputs it's just at the high
level what we're going to do is
we're going to you know take this dual
polynomial and massage it so that it
only has input of it only has support
and it puts up Hamming weight almost
that so we're going to do so using two
fixes neither of which independently is
enough to solve the problem but which
work in tandem to get us what we want
the first fix we're going to trade some
of the pure high degree of the inner
goal polynomial for the or function for
support size or effective support size
and that'll make us something that'll
give us some progress in the right
direction but in fixed to what we're
going to have to do is we're going to
have to look at the errors so the places
outside of the Hamming ball of radius
and where it has support and just like
forcibly kill off any mass that's I and
our places on such inputs okay so most
like slightly more detail this is what
we do we pretend that the inner function
or is it defined only on a smaller
number of variables M which gets us some
progress in the right direction but
moreover it's going to satisfy an
important additional property that the
total mass that this thing places on
high Hamming weight inputs is
exponentially small in our over m m to
the one-half for some parameter m okay
and then the in the second part and fix
two we're going to use a construction
due to Roseboro of insure stuff to again
kill off all of the mass place that hi
having we didn't put and then you do
this balancing argument so you you know
you take this correction term you
subtract it off of the space dual
polynomial that we've constructed and
that's going to have all of the
requisite properties with some pure high
degree which is the minimum of the pure
high degrees of these two terms you
balance these things out and you get
that the total that the combined dual
polynomial has pure high degree are to
the three-fourths which is what we
wanted
all right so I want to wrap up with a
couple of open questions in this area
that I think are really interesting so
sort of the the broader problem that I
want to understand in this areas can we
come up with new techniques for
understanding the approximate degrees of
specific functions let's have less
structure or different structure than
the problems that we've considered in
this talk and I'll give some examples of
what I mean by this in the context of
specific open questions so first problem
again one that motivated this talk is
whether there's an AC zero function you
know some circuit of constant depth that
has maximal approximate degree n so
there's a good candidate for this which
is due to street on which is circuits
computing the approximate majority
function so the aprox so I should say
that's the majority function it was a
symmetric function not an AC zero but it
has maximal approximate degree Omega n
however approximate majorities so
functions that are zero when they're
inputs have Hamming weight at most n
over three are one when their inputs are
Hamming weight at least two n over three
and can be anything otherwise are
computed by depth three AC zero circuits
okay
with essentially quadratic size so a
nice question is you know whether such
functions truly have maximal approximate
degree yeah and I think in doing so
we're going to you know really need to
understand we're really going to need to
develop new techniques to understand you
know these constructions that are based
on distributions over circuits so like
randomized constructions abductors a
serial circuits another question I like
which Sascha also mentioned is what's
the approximate degree of polynomial
size DNF so in terms of upper bounds we
know nothing in terms of lower bounds
the K distinctness function for large K
gives us something like n to the 3/4
again closing this gap is a really
interesting question
and there's a candidate so I'm not gonna
leave you totally in the dark the case
um function is another function that's
been extensively studied in quantum
query complexity where it's known to
have quantum query complexity
approaching n okay last open problem
whatever we can use approximate degree
in the polynomial method to understand
to solve like other long-standing open
questions and quantum query complexity
for functions that have you know very
different structure than these things
that are you know properties of a list
of numbers so one question I really like
is that of understanding the approximate
degree or quantum query complexity of
the triangle finding problem given a
graph represented by an adjacency matrix
and you want to determine whether the
graph contains a triangle so a very
influential line of work in quantum
algorithm shows that the best upper
bound is n to the one point two five but
we don't know any lower bounds for this
problem this is just this trivial lower
bound of n
there's questions just slow markdown on
Just Lunch
so it it really does something quite
similar to what Sasha did for
surjectivity
do as you you know you take your top
gate the fanon of the top gate is not
too high so you can write that does the
only low weight linear combination of
high degree things and then bash down
the error of the things that go into
there that's the idea but you know some
of the details of it are a little bit
different the questions
not so much of questions the comment
that I figured the one early paper that
I guess is not mentioned in this video
stops that the users are loops it's
approximate polynomials and uses a dual
polynomial method in particular is the
law of lineal and mission on approximate
inclusion explosion should should
feature it let's see yeah there's a
there's a nice line of work some of
which I think is due to Sacha as well
yeah great yeah so you have this problem
you have like a sequence of sets the
inclusion exclusion principle tells you
you know how to count how many things
are in the union of this thing but you
don't want to you know have to go all
the way down to intersections of like
almost everything almost the maximum
number of sets that you could consider
so yes you said what these works do is
you say you go out only to route an or
something set size and there you can
like approximate right so it's tight and
it's it turns out to be a polynomial
approximation the question and it's a
bit of a 93 so okay even earlier than
thanks your questions
okay let's think mark again
[Applause]